And for experts and emotion interview today.
Um,
we'll be speaking with Dr Lisa Parr who share her expertise on expressions of
emotion and chimpanzees.
Dr Par received her phd in psychology at Emory university and is now an
assistant professor in the division of Psychiatry and Behavioral Science and
directs the Comparative Research Laboratory at the Yerkes National Primate
Research Center,
uh,
examining emotional communication and social cognition in monkeys and apes.
A doctor [inaudible] has received several awards in her career,
including the Frank A.
Beach comparative psychology award from the American psychological association
as well as funding from the National Institute of Mental Health,
the National Science Foundation and the National Alliance for autism research.
And on a side note,
as a native Australian doctor,
par enjoys fishing,
cooking,
and riding her motorcycle.
So we will now turn to a very special experts and emotion interview with Doctor
Lisa Par.
Yeah.
So thanks for speaking with us today,
Lisa.
You're very welcome.
The morning,
every morning.
So what I wanted to start out asking you a bit about is what first got you
interested in studying emotions,
sort of where did it all begin for you?
Yeah,
that's an interesting question.
Um,
I think I'd have to trace it back to before I started Grad school.
I was working in a lab that was interested in laterality and asymmetries and we
were doing a project looking at facial asymmetries and chimpanzee you use,
and so my role is the technician was to go basically be the photographer and
take a lot of photographs of,
of chimpanzee users.
They were making lots of expressions and playing and interacting with one
another.
And um,
I wasn't really thinking too much about the goal of the project when I was
acting as the photographer.
But after a while,
you know,
you look at,
at their behavior and you know,
you,
you naturally start to have questions.
What do these expressions really mean and are they really able to interpret them
and do they communicate something about emotion,
like human facial expressions.
So that's where the sort of trajectory went from there.
That's really interesting.
So I'm going to ask you then a little bit about this trajectory because it's
something that I know a lot of people find so interesting.
I mean,
what you've done is conduct this groundbreaking research to sort of
systematically and objectively develop a coding system to quantify emotion
expressions for the first time,
you know,
in nonhuman primates in particular,
chimpanzees,
which you refer to as chimp facts.
Um,
and I wonder if you could say a little bit about the steps involved in
developing the system.
Right.
So,
um,
the system,
as you know,
the,
the facial action coding system was developed by Paul Ekman in the 1970.
So I can't take credit for the system itself and really was a brilliant idea and
still remains the gold standard for looking at,
at facial movement,
um,
in humans to this day.
And,
you know,
like I said,
um,
and we started to to think about chimpanzee facial expressions and what they may
mean,
and as a,
a sort of student to be theology,
I'm understanding about animal behavior.
One of the first questions was,
you know,
let's really try and quantify what these movements are.
And probably if I was studying a different species,
it may not have seemed so pertinent.
But when you watch a group of chimpanzees,
the just amazing depth of complexity in their facial expressions is really quite
daunting.
So the first thing that we had to do was,
was just create basically a language to describe what we were seeing.
And so that's,
that's where the chimp facts came.
So,
um,
basically paralleling the development of the human facts.
We first,
uh,
did some dissections to make sure that the facial anatomy of the chimpanzee was
similar to humans.
And that's important because the face itself is quite different.
The,
the structure and morphology of the,
of the chimpanzee face,
they have a very heavy brow ridge.
They don't have a fatty knows like we do are these fatty cheeks are reverted
lips.
So it's really quite a different palette that you're working with.
Um,
and we did confirm all 23 mimetic facial muscles in the chimpanzee similar to
humans.
And the next thing we did was a,
a little bit bizarre.
We actually did some intra muscular stimulations of the different muscles to
verify that when the muscle contract,
I'm going to make lots of weird facial to extent,
um,
that,
that actually produced the movements that we were seeing.
Um,
uh,
when the chimpanzees were making facial expressions so we could confirm that
specific facial movements were actually due to the action of,
of individual facial muscles.
And then it was really just a,
um,
a painstaking task of watching lots of video and isolating examples of the
particular movements and then creating the manual and the descriptions,
um,
which is,
uh,
you know,
um,
only a fraction of the,
of the complexity of the human facts,
but,
um,
nonetheless it,
it needed to be done.
So that's the basic process.
So what do you see as the parallels between,
you know,
as you said,
Paul Ackman's facial action coding system in humans and the system that you
developed for chimpanzees or chimp facts?
[inaudible]
well,
the system,
the system is identical in all of the different steps in the,
um,
you know,
the resources that it provides for you.
So,
um,
we have,
individual action unit similar to the,
to the human facts.
The numbers are identical because the musculature is identical.
And,
and basically if,
if you throw out a series of numbers to be,
I can tell you what that expression is in the,
you know,
a six,
a 12 and um,
and you know exactly what the expression is.
So it just gives us that objective tool to describe what we're seeing without
having to say,
is that a bared teeth?
Cause it kind of looks like a bared teeth,
but there's also this other movement in there and you know,
it is it really prototypical or not.
So it gives us the ability to,
to really describe that with a lot of precision.
I mean,
it's fascinating.
I'm sure you get many questions about what can we use chimp facts for.
And when you get asked these kinds of questions,
what do you think are the promises that can be used with this tool and coding,
you know,
systematically emotion expressions in the faces of chimpanzees?
Yeah.
Um,
you know,
I think the question still remain in terms of humans.
I think the real,
um,
fascinating part of,
of,
uh,
animal communication,
especially a,
a species as complex as a chimpanzee,
is what are all the nuances of the,
of the communication that they use.
And you know,
even in humans,
you know,
Paul Ekman described prototypical facial expressions,
these expressions of basic emotion like anger and fear.
And you know,
these are really hard emotion words.
Um,
but the,
the reality is that the everyday communication that we have is filled with
subtle nuances and,
and micro expressions and very low intensity versions of expressions.
We don't walk around all the time with these huge big on off static displays and
chimpanzee user are the same.
Um,
and you know,
like I said,
if I had studied with studying,
uh,
maybe,
maybe simpler species,
I don't want to use that without that word in quotes,
similar species,
uh,
you know,
it wouldn't have been maybe such an urgent need,
but because the chimpanzee is so,
there's really just such an amazing amount of complexity in how they communicate
with one another that,
you know,
it made it really necessary to develop it.
That tool.
And I also know you've talked a lot about the importance of context and
interpreting these expressions.
And I wonder if you could just say a little bit about that.
Yeah,
I mean that's part of the of the complexity is,
you know,
one expression is not tied with one context.
It's um,
you know,
they can be used across a range of different contexts.
Do you can,
you know,
see animals that have been involved in a fight bearing their teeth at one
another,
but then you can see a mother greeting her,
her infant and burying the teeth.
So here you have what appears to be the same expression you used in drastically
different contexts in it.
You know,
it raises the question,
you know,
what are these expressions really mean and how do they really function?
And at least to date,
um,
there,
there haven't been a lot of studies looking at that function that it's takes a
lot of time and a lot of,
um,
dedication to do those sorts of studies because you have to wait for the
expressions to occur.
And so,
um,
that's a big project for one that that really needs to be done.
But I'll give you an example of one data set.
My colleague and developing that,
the chimp facts,
Bridget Waller,
who's in the UK,
Portsmouth University,
um,
has done a study looking at place signaling and chimpanzees.
Chimpanzees have a very characteristic play face.
They dropped the mouth open and they usually keep the upper teeth covered.
Um,
but during certain play about sometimes you see flashes of the upper teeth and
it raises the question is that what does that additional movement communicating
in the context of play?
And what she found was that individuals who flashed the upper are usually a more
dominant or older than their play partners.
And when the upper teeth are flashed,
it extends the length of the playbook.
So it may signal something like,
you know,
we're,
we're a disparate Dyad,
I'm higher ranking than you are.
So there's some maybe some social tension there,
but when I flashed my upper teeth,
I'm signaling,
hey,
it's okay,
we can still keep playing.
You know,
it's,
it's okay.
So maybe like,
you know,
a younger sibling playing with their older brother and you know,
so there's,
there's a real,
um,
mediation of that interaction through the use of this additional movement.
And you know,
that isn't an expression in and of itself.
So until the chimp fax was created,
we wouldn't have had a way to really,
um,
very nicely quantify and describe these things.
And just a little bit,
I mean,
I know when people go about thinking that they want to train and become,
you know,
a certified facial action coder and that sort of human fax system,
it takes 80 to a hundred hours and you know,
these laborious tests that,
that people go through.
Um,
having been a facs coder myself and I just wonder if it's the same kind of
intensive training process when it comes to chimp facts too.
Yeah.
We really recommend people who want to use the system that they first become
certified on the human facts because it's,
it's such a,
uh,
the system is so much more in depth than humans because there are additional
movements that humans do that we weren't able to find in the chimpanzee.
Um,
that's sort of an interesting thing that,
because I guess you could speculate that it's because of the facial morphology.
The upper part of the face of the chimpanzee is not nearly as as mobile as the
human face.
For example,
they don't have eyebrows.
They have a heavy brow ridge,
but it's the same color as the rest of the head.
And so you don't get all the sort of upper facial signaling that that you do in
humans.
So it's a,
it's a reduced form of,
of the facts as a whole.
So we recommend that people first learn the human facts,
which yes,
it takes a long time.
Um,
but once they learn the human factor,
the chimp facts is really,
is really quite straight forward.
This is really interesting.
Just thinking about,
you know,
the development of this coding system for being able to quantify emotion
expressions and chimpanzees and I know a related line of work that you've done
has also looked at sort of emotion discrimination or recognition in chimpanzees.
And I wonder if you could say a little bit about your work here and their
ability to recognize or seemingly discriminate between different facial
expressions among other chimps.
Yeah,
that's a good question.
Um,
it was one of the first questions that we had.
We noticed the chimpanzees have a variety of,
of facial expressions just like humans and we wondered whether they saw them as
discrete categories.
Um,
so again,
I sort of have a part time career as a photographer,
uh,
spending a lot of time taking pictures of,
of chimpanzees and of course there are challenges and that they're always behind
a tree or something like that.
Um,
anyway,
we put together a,
a,
a really nice,
uh,
stimulus set of,
of photographs and we use a computer interface to test their recognition
ability.
It's a very straightforward task called the match to sample task.
They,
they actually use a joystick to manipulate a cursor on the computer screen.
Yeah,
it sounds,
it sounds kind of crazy,
but they're actually extremely good at it and they really love to do that sort
of task.
So they first see a picture of what we call the sample and then they see two
comparisons.
One matches the sample and it can match on a variety of different visual or,
or,
um,
you know,
content wise dimensions.
So the first thing would be simply to present them with a picture of an
expression in the matches,
the identical picture.
But then,
you know,
your,
your question is really about picture matching and not about expression
recognition.
So what we did instead is we gave them a picture of a facial expression is the
sample and the correct choice was a different individual,
but making the same category of expression.
And then the non match was every other expression category.
So we had all different combinations and we found that,
um,
without really any training at all,
they were able to match those basic categories,
uh,
across different individuals.
So,
um,
it just proved to us that these,
uh,
these facial signals are,
are very salient,
easily recognizable and a seem to store it into the same sort of categories
that,
that we were seeing,
which was,
which was nice.
Oh,
that's fascinating work.
And I'm incredibly impressed too as you say,
that they're able to complete this computerized task just as any,
you know,
human research participant might.
Yeah.
They,
um,
they're very good at that.
One question,
I'm sure you've been asked,
and I don't know if there's an answer to this,
but you found that they can reliably discriminate between emotion expressions
within their own species.
To what extent do you think there's any ability for cross species recognition
perhaps between people might ask you a chimp than a human?
And do we know that answer at this point?
You know,
we don't really know the answer at this point.
I think,
um,
you know,
because we,
we work in captivity in a laboratory environment,
there are restrictions in terms of,
um,
you know,
safety protocols.
We have to wear a surgical masks and shields to cover our faces and things to
prevent cross contamination.
And,
um,
and so it's question about how much the chimpanzees actually know about our
facial expressions.
Um,
you could certainly use facts to,
um,
compare similar facial expressions based on the movements that are involved and
see if the chimpanzees can tell,
hey,
that's a Aau 12 plus six,
I'm going to match that to the human [inaudible] six.
Um,
and those are definitely things that,
that we have lined up to do.
Um,
the other thing that we've done is simply try and use fax as a tool to match
homologous,
uh,
facial movements.
So,
um,
movements that we believe are derive from a common ancestor.
So could ask the question,
do chimpanzee expressions resemble any human,
uh,
basic facial expressions?
And when we do that,
um,
like I said,
chimpanzees don't have a lot of upper facial movements.
So if you kind of discount some of the upper facial movements,
you can match chimpanzee facial expressions to a surprising variety of everyday
human emotions like joy and surprise and,
and sadness and excitement.
Um,
and,
and those line up in terms of the actual movements that are,
that are used to produce those expressions.
Thank you so much for speaking about your work.
I know this is something that a lot of people in the,
you know,
study of human emotion,
want to know how much we can also understand the emotions of non humans.
And so your work has just done a really beautiful job beginning to lay those
steps out for how we can even begin to quantify,
you know,
something like an emotion expression.
And so I wanted to ask you,
you know,
it sounds like you have some steps in line for where you want to take the
research next.
And I wonder from your perspective,
sort of where do you see the future of emotion in this field headed?
That's a great question.
It's such a complicated topic and I'm not sure that we're much closer in the
last few years and really understanding at a philosophical level what emotion
and animals really is.
Um,
there are a number of,
uh,
exciting young investigators who are working in this area.
And you know,
I think just like in,
in human work,
what we need to be careful of is having really deep,
uh,
descriptions of behavior,
and understanding that behavior,
um,
in terms of the context in which the expressions are used and the subtle
nuances.
So these micro expressions.
And so it's really,
I think,
getting away from the kind of static pictures of prototypical expressions and
getting down into the,
into the trenches in terms of everyday communication and exactly what,
uh,
what the animals are doing.
And,
and I think for that there's going to need to be a little bit of a revolution in
how we study these sorts of things.
You know,
I can't ask my animals to,
you know,
sit behind the camera and look perfectly,
uh,
face forward and,
you know,
I'm studying them in that particular context.
So we need to,
you know,
find a way to get cameras on the ground and,
integrate,
um,
the perspective of lots of different cameras so that we can actually sort of get
down at their level and,
and,
um,
and um,
you know,
um,
look at it from that,
from that point of view,
from their point of view.
So what advice then do you have for future students who are thinking about
embarking in this study of emotion in particular,
studying in emotion,
you know,
in nonhumans chimpanzees for example.
Wow.
Um,
well be objective.
it's,
it's really,
really difficult to,
uh,
think about emotion and other animals without invoking our own emotion.
Um,
it's really just impossible because we see things through our eyes and,
um,
I think just back and being objective and making sure that,
you know,
it's the science and the results that are,
that are speaking,
um,
as opposed to,
you know,
using our own,
um,
you know,
perceptions and,
um,
you know,
we have to,
we have to just make sure that we're being as objective as possible and,
um,
it's challenging.
Well,
amidst all the challenges,
you've continued to do what I think is some of the most amazing work in this
field.
So I just want to thank you for speaking with us today and being part of this,
you know,
series and understanding emotion better.
That's an exciting thing.
Thank you very much for having me.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
So this concludes our experts in emotion interview with Doctor Lisa [inaudible]
from Emory university.